from Fox News House Republicans to vote
on Bill abolishing IRS eliminating
income tax vote on abolishing IRS part
of deal between speaker McCarthy and the
house Freedom caucus
Fox News digital has learned the house
will be voting on a Georgia Republican
rep buddy Carter's reintroduced fair tax
act that aims to reel in the IRS and
remove the national income tax as well
as other taxes and replace them with a
single consumption tax the vote in the
bill was made as part of the deal
between house Speaker Kevin McCarthy and
members of the House Freedom caucus and
was pushed forward in his quest for the
gavel last week okay full stop
the failures of the GOP in this midterm
are the greatest gift to all of us you
know why Kevin McCarthy thought he would
not need to negotiate with the freedom
caucus members because they were going
to have a red wave so pronounced the 20
or so vote holdouts would have been
completely irrelevant and then because
the GOP underperformed he had to go
crawling to members of the freedom
caucus as well as people like you know
it's like Matt Gates lawnmower and then
say okay fine what do you want and now
we get something as bold as abolishing
the IRS vote on the house floor it's not
going to happen no the Senate will
reject it but I want you all to
understand when the Democrats vote to
support the IRS when the Democrats
they've already voted to defend the 87
000 IRS agents when you're having dinner
with your family and your aunt Aetna is
like well the Republicans they're
eviling you'd be like yeah you know I
hear you but man the Democrats voted to
defend the IRS get your Democrat
relatives to defend the IRS in front of
everybody and see how well that goes the
IRS is actually a good thing Tim
no no no no no no I I actually agree
with you thank you so much for bringing
this up I mean the IRS they're pretty
much like those little uh you know
gnomes but but instead of uh also like
those little Christmas elves but instead
of leaving stuff they just take stuff
for themselves and without them who's
going to finance the next Epstein Island
right who's going to make sure that the
special interests get all their money
who's going to make sure that corn seed
oils are subsidized right it has to be
the IRS agents they're they're very Bold
and Beautiful Brave members of the
government that of course are not
working for a corrupted hijacked
government that of course is spending
our money and wasting it on special
interests so uh yeah we got to protect
the IRS guys personally I love being
rated for a 600 transactions on them I'm
looking forward to it well this is
what's going to happen you're getting a
letter in the mail it's going to say you
owe 73 dollars and you're going to be
like what what do I owe 73 dollars for
this is ridiculous and they're going to
have your list of transactions they're
going to say well we think that this
transaction was income and you're like
that was me moving like I moved money
from my checking account to my venmo
that's not new money nah it looks like
new money to us so you owe 73 good luck
you gonna call a lawyer lawyer's gonna
be elect for one thousand dollars I'll
send a letter that will get that 73.
you're gonna be like strongly worded
it'll get the 73 they'll knock it down
by about like 50 that's right you have
to pay like you know 38 or whatever I
guess if you're rich and you're like
it's the thought that counts it's the
principle of things but for the average
person you're gonna be gutted so we're
getting a lot of this I don't know
symbolic victories it's all symbolic and
it's it's all really lame there like
there is value in like the meme factor I
suppose in like the culture war or for
talking points but there's no substance
there it's all just you know it feels
good it does feel good it's fun I mean
like I said I love to meme I like cyber
bullying people in Washington as much as
the next libertarian you know but
but when it comes to good it does
there's no there's no there's no there
there
you know that this the Senate's gonna
turn it down it's not going to happen
but it's good to get the Democrats to
say we like the IRS yeah I I love
hearing abolish the IRS but don't tease
me with a good time
without letting me finish here come on
guys seriously this is this is not right
is if they actually did something but we
know that the unibody can't have that
yeah all right so so we have these
symbolic gestures that amount to nothing
they're cute won't change anything and
uh of course they're they're patting
themselves on the back look guys we did
this I mean you're pathetic I don't
seriously absolutely pathetic I don't
want to shoot the process in the foot
unnecessarily because it hasn't gone to
the Senate yet and it may get passed
through the Senate even if it does then
could Biden veto it I think Biden could
yeah they pass the inflation reduction
act with which major support from the
Republicans you think they're going to
pass a bill that's going to ban the IRS
well they're supposed I wish they should
they should at least get rid of all
those tens of thousands of new agents
that are going to be hounding poor
people and the latest reports that are
coming out in 2022 the IRS
overwhelmingly went after and targeted
poor people more than they did people
with significant amount of income
they're doing this in order to of course
keep people in line as they literally
print money out of thin air this is such
a just a disrespectful slap in the face
to anyone paying attention here as our
economy is being deliberately destroyed
in order to push a great reset we're
here today and there's no going back
from this we have this little symbolic
gesture it's nothing I I do enjoy the
optimism though I'm kind of getting the
feeling that Luke doesn't like the
government just a little just a tiny
yeah we we were at Turning Point USA and
Luke I think was saying defund the IRS
or abolish the IRS and all these young
Republicans were like yeah and now you
see the Republican leadership in the
house proposing that we do it so like
not the leadership they didn't want to
do this well we got they got the
leadership to do it they got Kevin
McCarthy to do it so you know they are
supposed to represent the will of the
people regardless and so maybe the will
of the people is Shifting and people are
listening to that I put a poll in the
chat abolish the IRS four percent said
no yeah I want to know who these four
percent are yeah
I don't think they're illiterate people
I don't think you can fix politics with
politics that's the problem I'm at the
four percent is the people that couldn't
read the poll yeah they accidentally hit
the wrong button oh shoot oh it's it's
shifting though now it's it went three
or four so it's like as more votes come
in there's about 2 700 it's people are
saying yesterday they voted to defund
the 87 000 agents and then today they
voted to completely abolish the entire
program no they're going to okay so they
voted to get rid of the 87 000 agents
and the Democrats all voted in favor of
these agents no but that does matter I
mean we're not it's not going to go
anywhere the Senate's going to reject it
but seriously that's going to be in
every political ad in 2024. every
commercial is going to be like rocana
voted to support 87 000 new IRS agents
to Target your small bank account it's
it's it every single one's going to say
no way I think it's gonna I mean we're
too far away especially when it comes to
people's attention especially when it
comes to the upcoming election there's
no way they're going to remember this
um I I just don't see it personally
myself and you know the Democrats
wanting more government and more IRS
agents what a shocker even if they do
run ads though I mean you have these
people on the left right now I mean
they're going to cheer for it anyways
they're going to say okay yeah that's
that's the virtuous thing to do we
should tax these people we should tax
the rich that's what it's going to get
to redistribute the wealth
when they hear that they're gonna start
saying well it's a very important
service provided to to maintain our
government I mean we don't we're not
anarchists democracy
their weapons Luke did you hear that
what someone said we're not anarchists
but of course they're they're all status
commies
in the parks department don't get me
started on that uh but but seriously
Ukraine has to get their money right yes
why do you like dislike the parks
department because it pisses me off the
way
operate is absolutely nonsensical it's a
park it doesn't need bureaucracy it
doesn't need government and for the
government to intervene especially in
places like New York City because I
lived in New York City I loved New York
City And Then There came the parks
department that literally started to
arrest people give people summonses and
put them in court because they dared to
walk through a park at a certain time
that they that the state the parks
department didn't like that yeah that
that to me is absolutely insane
Draconian and and just top-tier
communism that I don't get me my blood
pressure's gonna go upstairs should
police the parks because otherwise
they're hubs for crime like like at
night people wait until you learn about
poor neighborhoods Ian like and they all
got to keep them clean to the parks and
you got to pay people to go do that but
how much funding do they really need I
don't know not I wouldn't think a lot
but I could be wrong
in like the year 1800 you know there's
no income tax yeah they did fine and
there was a lot of prosperity and there
was of course what do you mean there was
a lot of killing of Native Americans in
the 1800s like a lot of just but also
before 1913 right before the Federal
Reserve was enacted before there was the
creature from Jekyll Island before there
was this larger kind of income tax
levied against everyone else how did the
government run
pretty well on the limited basis and
private business and private Enterprise
was allowed to prosper and it did and
the roads were built magically and they
were still there magically it's not
magic it's of course Common Sense
whenever you have the government taken
away from people you have them depriving
them of any kind of prosperity of any
kind of Liberty of any kind of freedom
and if you think the government has a
duty to redistribute wealth you're an
absolute lunatic who is obviously just
facilitating the larger transfer of
wealth of your money to of course the
big Banks the big corporations that
truly do call the shots at government
and the most powerful people are only
enriched by more government look that's
racist I don't give a damn what it is
it's the truth and I'm speaking my
truths here because because hello house
can you see it well make a counter
argument how long until they uh write an
article saying Republicans effort to
abolish the IRS is rooted in white
supremacy I guarantee it exists it'll be
soon a hundred percent it exists because
they probably wrote it about
Libertarians already it probably already
yeah it's probably already you just gave
him great headline idea so next week I
would say Media Matters get on it you
write that thing I'm a person of color
so so they can't make that argument
personally I'm trans racial you can be
transgender actually so I think I found
I think about the opposite how federal
tax law hurts black Americans thank you
which is probably yeah so actually the
IRS is racist yes the tax codes racial
disparities well we got to get rid of
all that yes to counter your argument a
little bit Luke is that I think a lot of
the things like the power Monopoly
you're talking about could happen in the
private sector as well and so you need
some form of government to protect the
Common Man from
mobs and uh mafias and things until you
have another Mafia make up to fight the
mafias you have less Mafia technically
the mafia was created and made as
powerful as they are because of the the
prohibition because of the Banning of
alcohol which was a stupid idea because
the government going around and
poisoning people just to prove a larger
Point here this is what led mafias to be
as powerful as they are you look a lot
of the cartels they wouldn't exist if it
wasn't for the War on Drugs the biggest
Mafia of all the government facilitating
this larger kind of Mafia growth also
NASCAR
without prohibition you don't get NASCAR
what happens is that's true this
government that is actually true the
NASCAR got started because dudes were
souping up their cars to get away from
the cops when they were when they were
running shine oh yeah yeah
so what you're saying is if there was no
government
if there wasn't government maybe the
government is a good thing after all
yeah no because they're still Indy and
NASCAR only turns left it's the laziest
racing there's Indy 500 racing that
where they turn left and right NASCAR's
just left I'm sorry Mark I know you love
it but it's just left turns it's left
turns and crashes that's all anyone
cares about I like Indy 500 that sounds
fun Indy 500 right you say they turn
right and left right and left right both
wow but the point I'm trying to make is
that rather than just demonize quote the
government just acknowledge that our
federal government's way too big it's
too influential in people's lives it
needs to be reduced in size not that
there should never be any government
ever because I think some government is
extremely valuable in protecting common
people from corporations and things yeah
how dare you that's what police forces
is like a local government all the all
the big monopolies right now are as
powerful as they are abuse so much power
and and get away with so much big Pfizer
big agriculture all those companies get
away with it because of their
connections and manipulating with
government Ian's saying like a fire
department is good he's not saying no no
he's saying the government needs to be
there to keep the corporations in check
right but I'm saying the government is
there to make the corporations
monopolies you're arguing against the
current iteration of government which is
massive power structures Ian's basically
saying there is some degree of
government that's fine
we don't need the bureaucracy that
supports big big farm and all that we
don't need police departments or fire
departments not gonna be private but we
do need at least one thing of parks
department oh yeah
most important one hands down yeah
nothing else the government literally
just becomes a guy in a park being like
you can't come in have you been talking
to Mike cernovich about it he just had a
revelation about how awesome the US
parks are no he's like everyone should
the US parks are beautiful and they're
awesome yeah and they should be
preserved obviously but you could do
that independently you could do that
privately you don't need a parks
department arresting people for walking
in nature or camping or camping that
that to me is one of the biggest
ridiculous ideas that they could they
could micromanage you being in nature
privatization of land and and property
and stuff like that does preserve
property if you want to save endangered
species the best thing you can do is
have someone that has the resources get
a bunch of them on their private land so
no one can hunt them and they can take
care of them and then that will save the
species there's tons of species that
have been saved throughout the whole
world because of privatization same
thing down in uh in in Africa there's a
lot of a lot of yeah there's a lot of
people that uh
um privatize the land for safaris and
stuff and people think or and I'm not
sure if as far as the right word because
it's not a hunt where it's just like
sightseeing that they do they can see
wild animals and I probably use the
wrong turns good but but it but what it
does is it preserves the land and it
preserves the animals because there's a
financial incentive to preserve the land
and preserve the animals so people can
see them you know it's like there's
there's a way to monetize things in a
positive way they're like you can
absolutely use the incentive of profit
to have good results that is one of the
most obvious things living in modern
society it's it's almost it's so obvious
that people don't see it it's so
prevalent that people don't see it but
privatization is generally a good thing
now it's not to say that there aren't
problems or can't be problems but
privatization versus government it's
almost always better for privatization
because at the very least you're not
adding
you're not adding legal violence yes
thank you thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time